Speaker 1: You know, I believe last week we
tried to talk to Isaiah from Arkadelphia and
we had a technical problem.
Let's try Isaiah.
We didn't get on last week, did we, Isaiah?
Speaker 4: We can you can you understand me
now?
I can.
So there's no loud background noise of some
variety.
Speaker 1: I'm hearing no power tools, I'm
hearing no deli slicers or weights being dropped.
It's very clear today.
Speaker 4: You know, I don't own a deli slicer.
I think it'd be cool.
If I did.
I'd be moving up in the world.
Yeah, that and I was just curious.
I've noticed that a lot on the left because
of.
Speaker 3: Or out of
Speaker 4: order, people on the left don't
like to acknowledge that China and Russia
are really threats, and I'm not going to call
out specific names.
But when looking at, I'm sure you're familiar
with what's going on with Belarus, but for
your audience, the nation of Belarus, which
is basically a puppet of Russia, is essentially
engaging in human and human trafficking and
espionage to basically sabotage the border
of the European Union.
And I feel like if you ever bring up that,
hey, these countries.
May not necessarily align with U.S. foreign
policy that we may disagree with at times
that does not mean they are good countries.
They are threatening to the liberal democratic
world order.
You feel like this is something that needs
to be acknowledged more often.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
You know, you're very much you're it's a very
astute point, which is there's a contingent
of the left that I basically make every effort
not to engage with.
I just don't I don't find them interesting.
These are lefties who in in the 1960s and
70s in Argentina, when my parents were growing
up, they were all over the place and it was
sort of like the the west is bad people.
And it doesn't matter if anyway, if you if
you're a part of the West and you say anyone
else is doing something that's bad, you're
an imperialist, you're whatever.
It's a really old script.
And when I see these folks now, it just reminds
me of the people that my parents described
kind of my parents very much on the left in
Argentina in the 60s and 70s.
But they found those supposed leftists really
is interfering with social democratic goals,
not not actually helping.
I try not to engage with them because it's
just so boring.
It's so, it's so passé.
But you're absolutely right.
There are people like, for example, if you
look at the comments of my recent clip where
I said, Hey, you know what?
A lot of the China virus xenophobia that we're
seeing against Asian-Americans, it's disgusting.
There's no place for it.
But here's some actual stuff that we could
look at that China's doing that we should
be concerned about.
It doesn't align with my values and a lot
of the comments are.
But David, the U.S. does bad stuff too.
Or you didn't mention this one thing that
the U.S. we're not talking about that we're
not talking.
We're just on point.
We're having a conversation where I'm pointing
out, Hey, here's things that don't align with
my values.
I'm not saying go to war.
I'm not saying anything else.
And you're absolutely.
Speaker 4: Yeah, it's it's especially disappointing
to me because I'm fairly young.
I was born after nine eleven, and what got
me engaged with politics is every single day
growing up, being reminded a war at war in
Afghanistan, Iraq and should not be.
I know people who serve or just a few years
old or me served in Iraq also know people
whose parents served in Iraq.
Yeah, in Iraq and Afghanistan.
So that was an ever present thing.
So when I voted for for Biden, I live in Arkansas,
so my vote doesn't really matter by still
voted for him.
And just him getting out of Afghanistan, even
with all the issues afterwards, wasn't that
for me?
And then when I saw the West.
Any time anyone would say OK, but the Taliban
is still bad and China moving in, and their
influence is also bad.
Mm hmm.
It's like two things can be true at once.
The basis of being against a war in Afghanistan
or something like that is right.
You don't want destabilizing and.
More than sure,
Speaker 1: yeah, there's a lot of people where
it's like, it sounds like they they say, OK,
either China is doing something that's bad
or the U.S. is bad and it's like, Hey, hold
on a second.
The U.S. has a history of doing bad things
and here stuff, some stuff China's doing that
we do.
It's the black and white thinking is is disturbing,
and I'm glad you're thinking and talking about
this stuff.
Speaker 4: I was also curious, did you did
you vote in the recent Argentina elections?
Speaker 1: I did not know.
I moved to the U.S. when I was five, so I've
never been registered to vote in Argentina.
And my my documents aren't even current.
So if I wanted to vote in Argentina first,
I would have to renew my documents to be up
to date.
Update where I'm living.
Register as someone who's living in another
state and wants to vote.
You know, I just have.
I've not I've not done it.
I've never voted in Argentina.
Speaker 4: I saw the.
Peronist party suffered a setback, but I,
to be completely honest, just don't know enough
about Argentine politics than that with any
of the newer parties are actually that much
different in any way.
Speaker 1: Well, just from the last 30 seconds,
you know, more than ninety nine point nine
percent of Americans.
So consider that.
Consider that a success.
Speaker 4: I just know that South American
politics, like the people, like to be populists
and say power to the people, and then it's
one family controls the party and pockets
all the money.
Yes.
Speaker 1: That's very often the way it goes.
No, you're at.
You're.
But hold on a second.
You're not criticizing America when you say
that.
Speaker 4: I mean, I'm just like, oh, no,
I was meaning specific, I know
Speaker 1: I'm kidding around there are people
that the same people you were talking about
earlier, they would hear you say that and
they would go.
But the U.S. has families.
Speaker 4: I think they would say, like, Well,
we have the bushes, you know, like the Bush
family.
Three.
I will say Arkansas is a getting kind of a
dynastic thing.
I don't know if you've kept up with this.
Sarah Huckabee Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is the only candidate now she's going to be
governor.
All the others dropped out and endorsed her.
It's crazy.
Her father was, I think, for like 13 years
here.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Mike Huckabee was a longtime governor.
All right, my friend.
Listen.
You've said it all.
I'm going to let you go, OK?
OK, thanks.
All right.
Very good.
Guys, let's take a quick break.
I'm still taking calls.
We're going to take a quick break and then
go right back to the phones in a moment.
Stay with me.